like you make all the mistakes you're
like oh it's not bad you could drop a
baby the baby is fine you can do
whatever maybe it's fine now you can do
a lot of traffic did you drop the baby
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys today we have with us Mr
Jesus
welcome back man people love you here
yeah amazing time amazing time yes your
friends are [__] awesome dude let me
go to my shows really oh hell you're
drinking with them and I'm like dude
they can party bro [__] yeah yeah froze
like uh the ones in especially in
Modesto dude they were [__] awesome
the Modesto JK fans yeah those ones are
listed
[Laughter]
they don't all know each other but they
all do that y'all dude like you could be
in Texas you could be in California but
they gotta let you know I saw you on JK
news exactly oh that's the thing that
they tell you and oh I was at a so um I
remember I had a show and then uh I went
to a bar random bar right nobody from
the show was there but some girl just
kept staring at us and I I where I was
uncomfortable I was like listen lady I'm
not a piece of me all right I have a kid
at home watch yourself gonna watch this
and then she [__] comes up to me hey
I just are you from JK new did you well
I was like oh yeah I was on chicken she
couldn't believe that I was in her Town
it was like a small town she just
couldn't she was like she came up to me
like four times it's like dude I just
what is going on right now like I just
saw you stuff that's so cool it's like
and that's that was pretty cool she was
just like blown away she was just like
why are you here why are you in this
town like what's happening hey our fans
do enjoy you man I got we were just
talking about this the other day they
really really took a liking to you and
uh I don't know why yeah I did so uh
you're getting replaced
seats yeah uh we made you bring the same
jacket so it's not weird
stunned the eyes right so it's happening
dude I'm glad to be here man it's
[__] awesome oh yeah man how is it uh
is it easy yet being a dad uh no hell no
dude look at my look at my face dude I
am so tired how many months have you
been to Dad now three months he just
turned three months on the second the
hardest is he pretty chilly yet I don't
know guess what dude it gets better he's
teething this thing called teeth does
that bite you no no no he just left
somewhere and I was like that's not your
mama started dude you better chill out
with that [__]
I'm just like dude it's weird when he
has like a chew toy he just like
drooling and I'm like hey what do that
don't make eye contact I can do that
dude
you're just like your mama right now you
better come that [__] down I'm kidding
it's gross but he's teething so he's
being nuts right now do you wake up with
their wife when she feeds and or not uh
I'm the one waking up all night I do a
night shift because she works in the
daytime yeah
the humongous tits dude I got the little
face yeah and then you hold the baby
they suck on the titties yeah I get
yelled at him I yell at him when he goes
too hard I'm like hey
because you've got it attached to yours
motherhood is so special interest
yourself in the roll now you're being
just like me dude you ever start going
out of yourself I know right sometimes I
just play with them I'm in the bathroom
I'm cleaning them
no anyways
how many times do you wake up at night
uh right now it's every four hours
you know what's [__] crazy yeah you
you have a kid right and then the first
nine months I would say it's like
probably one of the hardest times of
your life and then during those times
you're waking up multiple times a night
and you're like how the [__] does anyone
have more than one right oh yeah then
literally a month after you're like dude
I think I could handle enough yeah you
should say that I'm not there yet I
don't know if I could do another one
like right back to back you're in the
first nine months man we'll we'll see
yeah he already has this there you have
the [__] Thousand Miles there of like
I have a book and slept on my mind
because I did the whole like I did the
whole thing like you know what I mean
like she's like I don't know how we're
gonna do and I was like you know what I
got it I tried to be like oh you try to
be super good baby
I got it after the third I was like I'm
gonna kill this [__] dude you didn't
think so you don't understand here's the
thing dude you're going like this for
[__] three hours right and then you
look down this motherfucker's just like
you're not doing [__] dude and I'm just
like bro go to sleep like how much more
of this can I do and then your back
starts aching at places you didn't know
that could ache so so what happens if
you just put the baby in the cart I
think he'll die I think it'll die if you
just let him just be he'll cry don't cry
forever forever forever piercing like
they're three neighbors down can hear
yeah so you feel bad you're like not
even for yourself you're like [__] I
don't want to wake the neighbors up you
don't go on shot
hell yeah dude you don't do that there's
some points have you ever I've gotten to
a point where I'm just like sometimes
I'll ground like and I'm like whoa whoa
dude it's your [__] child it's your
baby dude and I'm like oh sorry where am
I [__] I blacked out right now I must
forget he's my kid dude both noise
canceling headphones I put on the mouth
doesn't work what about that thing in uh
what is it a quiet place remember when
she puts the baby in the thing puts the
oxygen tank in the [__] close the
thing so it doesn't make sound oh I'm
gonna find that on Amazon real quick
dude you know what Jill's mom did she
was like you know what we used to do
back in the day I just put like a little
bit of rum in the milk oh yeah like damn
I don't know if that's a good idea
yeah that's why he's uh in prison right
now yeah yeah yeah well your son's in
prison
who did that like that's just the theme
back in the day you know if your babies
aren't chilling like that that's not a
Mexican thing I think it might be maybe
tequila hey Mom she was like
she was like putting the baby to sleep
and I was like oh yeah mom thinks you
know he cries a lot you know and she's
just like oh next time
put him in the room and just let him cry
and shut the door
why don't you do that because it's
abused my kids over there like
and she's just like mopping so I knew
she did that to me you know what I mean
but she's a veteran though all of us
probably grew up like that right right
yeah but that's why I can't cry no more
and let it all out when I was a young
age there's no tears left
cried out they do cry like their life is
over like the whale yeah because he's
like teenager like spontaneously just
like we're all chilling we're sleeping
it's like three in the morning and then
he'll just go
[Laughter]
yeah so I was screaming and my girl's
just like
um she walks in the room she's just like
like
yeah he's like a
he's like look
look he's not sucking anything in
there's no spongeness going on right now
they can't even see like two feet in
front of them
he gets it dude he freaking gets that's
so funny you say that because in Warzone
or just a Call of Duty in general in
public server you can always hear some
Mexican dude with a baby in the back
I'm trying to find like a little like
house and I lay down on the bottom and
I'm just [__] hurry up dude the
circle's closing
look at my friends where are you dude
I'm like dude I'm [__] in a fight
right now with my baby
so I don't recommend War Zone in and
taking care of a baby your parents help
out at all no they're live in Arizona so
oh [__] oh yeah they came they came to
visit the baby and it was like and then
left the next day so like old school and
my girl's just like
I don't know I don't even know how to
put this she's very like um like
um we're just gonna they came in we have
hand sanitizer so oh she had rules for
them you know what I mean she's very
Whole Foods yeah she's Whole Foods as
[__] right now dude that girl they like
that she's Whole Foods as [__] this so
she's like we're just gonna if we can
get a couple of yeah get a couple of my
dad is always okay what happened
[Laughter]
now for now until he gets stronger yeah
please and my dad's like scratching his
nuts okay
after the sanitizer yeah my dad's on
your ground is nuts I'm gonna see the
baby let me see the baby like dude relax
I'm gonna get a good grip you know like
it's not a ball dude grab his head my
mom she's Mexican she is she's a second
generation that's what happens second
generation exactly she's Americanized
they get Americanized they start voting
for the wrong people that's another
[__] story a lot of moms with their
first kid is super like that though yeah
I think that's what it is first kid the
first one and the second one you're like
like you make all the mistakes you're
like oh it's not bad you could drop a
baby the baby is fine you can do
whatever it is fine yeah you can do a
lot of [__] rob the baby today's video
is brought to you by Warby Parker Warby
Parker offers you everything you need
for happier eyes is smiling you see
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
eye exams and you can shop with them
online or in stores and glasses start at
95 bucks including the prescription
lenses try Warby Parker's free home try
on program order five pairs of glasses
to try at home for free there's no
obligation to buy ship free and includes
a prepaid return shipping label so
what's cool about these things is you
take a personal at-home quiz right and
then you get to pick five of your liking
for this try at home program is pretty
awesome it comes straight to your
doorsteps right and then at home you'll
be like
oh I like that or you go
I don't like that man and you don't have
to commit to buying it yeah you could
test drive them walk around your house
put on different outfits and go hmm this
one actually looks really good oh this
one actually didn't look as good as I
thought on the website and you can
finally get the perfect pair I like
these that's why I kept these so try
five pairs of glasses at home for free
at warbyparker.com off the record I read
this one a lady she was saying like she
has three kids the first one when they
eat dirt she she rushes it to the uh
emergency and the second one she's like
she just waits to see what happens and
then the third one she was like does he
even need dinner oh yeah
I have a star I've never but told
[__] Jill because I'm [__] scared
and I need Tyga to be maybe like 12
before I tell her yeah this is a great
place to get it out right I know these
[__] are gonna set it straight
okay all right well make sure you clip
this [__]
baby right like it's born during the
time where like you know no one can go
out you [__] only get two steaks two
toilet papers at the grocery store so
everyone's like locked up so he can't go
to like babysitters he can't do anything
like that so I I spend pretty much most
of my time taking them to the parking
like that's his fun place to play so
there's a little Park where we used to
live and at about
I would say like even a year and a half
already he got pretty good at climbing
like he was like really good at climbing
like climbing the the net that goes off
the side oh yeah you can go down the
slide by himself like [__] he's ready
for the Army dude he's really good so
you know as the kid gets better and
better you're you're like children's
things get stronger and stronger oh okay
so there's one time and I have videos of
him going up by himself running jumping
going down the slide [__] with Steve
and [__] yeah one time he goes up to uh
you know the the pole where he can slide
up and down yeah he goes up to the pole
it's probably like probably like this
this tall right yeah he holds on to the
pole and I'm like oh because he's
probably gonna slide down he just falls
off oh he falls off hits the ground I'm
like what the [__] can I run over there
grab him and he didn't even cry or
anything and I'm like oh [__] did I did
he break his bones he's paralyzed in the
spine and I was like babies are strong
and resilient
like you come back home and Jill's like
oh how's the park it was awesome we had
such a good time nobody fell off a pole
he's over here walking like this
what the [__] is this
I think that's normal like we all have a
thing that we're just like keeping a
secret I think a guy that one was crazy
so you thought he was gonna grab it and
slide down but he grabbed it and just
went bye-bye
they're like yeah he went nah because
they're they're like learning while
exploring their boundaries at the same
time sometimes you're like oh he's
learning some [__] and then like he's
like looking at a [__] doorknob and
he's like oh shitty [__] then he like
licks it or something
figure it out
he's learning let him explore that's my
son let him suck on the doorknob you
know
he's trying to figure out what it does
son yeah you can't guess the next move
yeah
you think you know but you don't and
then you also can't hinder it because
it's going against nature yeah you're
like you gotta let him suck on a couple
things yeah
my little brother did to a mannequin it
was just like straight grab it under the
[__] dress and we're like oh I was
like oh Mom
he just had to be Latino I guess
it's going in there going in for a
little grab how has it affected your uh
like your work schedule and stuff like
traveling dude I put more and more now
because I'm just like dude I wish I
could take care of the baby but I gotta
I gotta work
guys excuse again the farther the
cheaper yeah it helps but it's just it's
more like the pressure it would like
like I need to figure out more Revenue
like that's the other thing I'm just
like as a dad you're like I gotta figure
out like yeah get to the next level but
other than that it's like you know I
want him to go to college you know what
I mean so that's the only thing that I
would be like that's stressful but not
really it's just I don't know but it's
cool having a baby like it just seen
like his face reactions and stuff like
every once in a while you're just like
oh that's pretty cool but like what you
just said right now earlier about the
you had like a secret that you don't
tell the other person like dude I had
this I had happened to me when I do the
night shifts and then like I'm supposed
to feed them and the alarm went off and
I just I slept through it
no I slept through three of them dude I
woke up like refreshed and I'm like I'm
like wait a minute is my girl's just
like
um It's like because it was like a
little bus he's like he's being fussy
already at six
supposed to eat at eight I'm like
oh [__] he hasn't ate at all like at all
through the night I'm like holy [__] so
I had to be like yeah I don't know
what's going on and I'm just I felt so
bad yeah I'm like dude I just [__] up
now he's doing an intermittent fast yeah
yeah you know what I mean [__] and who's
on his cut dude he's bleeding out bro
he's [__] getting that cut right now
dude
on his diapers
all six packed out like [__] Jesus
abs
like Brad Pitt from Fight Club yeah come
on do we want a hot baby or not is what
I want to know dude did that happen to
you too like sleeping through like
feeding alarms and stuff if you say no
I'm a good dad I really did it didn't
really didn't I got pretty responsible
so I would never
[Laughter]
mind
yeah yeah you watch them go down there
how long does it take until they can
sleep yeah dude once you find out let me
know nine months plus it was some people
I've known like the first three months
already sleeping 12 hours a night yeah
what about that what about that sleep
training [__] that's what we did we did
the state training for one week what's
that when can you start doing it you let
him cry itself out till he gets tired
like that oh sure yeah so I think the
doctor or the pediatrician told us like
in the first six months you really want
them to get like crazy nutrients because
it's a crazy nutrients I'm pretty sure
she said it like that I want you to get
crazy [__] Nutri
ents developing and then then they're
like okay you can start sleep training
at like around six months
so at six months that's when we we tried
it for the first time and then like the
first day so you just pretty much like
you feed them and do all everything and
then you're trying to train them to not
eat in the middle of the night so you
put them in the room and you go away and
literally the [__] was crying
for like 40 minutes straight oh yeah
I've heard of babies crying for three
hours straight and then you know the
moms are always like oh [__] don't want
to go back
okay oh my God oh my God we have to we
have to do it all the dads are like no
no it's gonna be worth it dude I'm gonna
be [__] just like dude let it [__]
cry dude
really Zone in here yeah but the second
day was like 30 minutes and then 20
minutes and then pretty soon after one
week didn't cry anymore but then after
that there's still some like relapse
here and there because they're used to
it yeah but then after that they they
get okay cool I'm gonna get all my meals
during the day I don't need it at night
anymore wow it's gonna get there dude
I'm already how about just hook the baby
up to some breast milk IV and [__] like
all the people if they get the vitamin B
stuff dude I can't wait to see Joe with
your dad he's gonna be like dude
you see this kid would have look at baby
he just like are you kidding a cold
full of nutrients non-stop babies
got that Karate Kid robe
a Trippy [__] baby dude you'd be like
[__] Master Splinter and [__]
that little rats playing with the Rising
Sun training is [__] puppies
[__] sick dude does your baby make it
more into your material now like because
it's like oh yeah I'm writing more of
not I'm not trying to do like I don't
want to be that [__] common but just
be like oh I have all these [__] dad
jokes it's like nah like I I told my
jokes and I add the baby in it I see
like I'm talking about everything
everyday stuff and he just happens to be
a part of the joke you know what I mean
but right now he's barely meeting this
[__] dude I don't know if I like
him man you know I don't know if we're
bonding dude sometimes we're beefing
sometimes we're not what do you guys
beef about oh dude him not letting me
sleep dude him taking over uh his mom
all the time and I'm like dude I'm
trying to I'm saying what's going on
what's Happening
real [__] tired all the time dude
when [__] puts you to sleep I'm like
Hey I'm third he made me so tired today
a little [__] get a tire one
more time dude that's swear to God
that's what we'd be beefing about dude
yeah I can't wait to start getting those
snacks you know what I mean so I can
start you know
he's not there yet but when he starts I
can't wait dude I can't wait till I
start killing the snacks you know when
do they start eating like more solid
food whatever you want six
I heard it was like yeah six months to
like a year it's like they get mush and
then like after like mush yeah like
[__] baby food like [__] Blended
zucchini or some [__] you know and then
later on when they start I know right
look at them that's wax I can't eat I
remember the first time the first time I
was like this is a [__] game changer
the first time because the baby relies
on you for everything uh yeah
the first time it's weird I think he
found I feel like he found that out like
nine months later he's like wait whoa
this baby like relies on me dude I gotta
do everything for the [__] baby but
the first time I taught him to like he's
like I want water and I like you go to
the fridge and you go like this
oh he's good and then it was like one
after another like they know how to do
their [__] but while he's doing that the
water spills it does
oh a little bit yeah then I can see how
it gets to the hey give me a beer you
know
yeah that's tight yeah he just starts
doing his own Tycoon look at that bar
hey give me a beer
my girl's doing the whole like lipstick
sign language baby silent milk she like
milk I'm like this he ain't gonna [__]
him
okay my baby just look at her like
I'm looking at him
hey man that's your mama dude
how can you save milk she just feed the
[__] baby he's [__] starving you
know she's waiting for his response and
he's just like
yeah you got it
got it I'm like you don't got it feed
the [__] at least teach him real sign
language
thank you